Bitte schön.
Ich möchte ganz schnell ein paar allgemeine Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Jutta Lippert.
Jutta Lippert.
Sollten Sie bitte Ihren Vorname, Nachname, die musst du haben?
Ja, Jutta schreibt sich J-U-T-T-A.
Und der Nachname Lippert schreibt sich L-I-P-P-E-R-T.
Jutta mit ist doppelt-T.
Ja.
Doppelt-T, oder?
Ja, doppelt-T.
Okay.
Und Herr oder Frau?
Frau, Frau Lippert.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 15. Februar 1966.
Okay.
Sind Sie bereitet?
Ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder.
Okay.
Und was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Architektin.
Architektin.
Okay.
Frau Lippert, was führt Sie zu uns?
Was wird bestätigt haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, ich habe so seit circa zwei Stunden,
ist mir plötzlich unwohl.
Mir ist schlecht.
Ich habe zweimal erbrochen.
Und ich habe so einen Druck im Oberkörper.
Ich habe auch im Oberbauch.
Mehr beim Oberkörper, im Hinterbrustbein.
Hinterbrustbein.
Fühlen Sie Schmerzen hinter dem Brustbein?
Ja, richtig.
Schmerz ist ein Druck.
Und diese starke Übelkeit.
Ein Druckgepült.
Ja, ein leichter Druckschmerz.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie zweimal erbrochen haben.
Wie sieht das Erbrochene aus?
Ein bisschen gelblich, schleimig, gelblich.
Was war es, Blut im Erbrochene?
Kein Blut.
Könnten Sie bitte sagen, wo die Schmerzen am Sterb stehen?
Also so mehr hier im Brustkorbbereich?
Ganz ganz.
Und etwas auch so unterhalb der Rippen.
Aber mehr hier oben.
Oben, okay.
Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Nicht so richtig.
Und wie viele Schmerzen?
Auch eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10.
Wenn ein sehr leichter Schmerz ist, dann ist es ein unerwäglicher Schmerz.
Na, 4 bis 5.
Ja.
Und,
2 Stunden haben Sie diese Schmerzen.
Vor circa 2 Stunden.
Hatten Sie etwas ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Nein.
Bevor diese Schmerzen aufgebildet?
Nein, das waren noch vor dem Frühstück.
Vor dem Frühstück begann das mit den Beschwerden.
Gestern Abend habe ich ganz normal etwas Brot gegessen,
etwas Tee getrunken, aber nichts Besonderes.
Besonderes.
Gibt es,
gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Ja, haben Sie irgendwelche Vermutung?
Ich habe solche Schmerzen noch nie vorher gehabt.
Und diese Übelkeit habe ich noch nie vorher gehabt.
Übelkeit auch.
Und,
wie war,
wie war Ihr Erbrechen?
Ja, ganz plötzlich.
Und war es ganz plötzlich, plötzlich und,
wurde erst schlecht und übel und auch etwas schwindelig.
Und dann kam dieser Druck im Brustkorb.
Und dann habe ich auch schon das erste Mal Erbrauchen.
Wie war die Menge?
Ja, haben Sie viel Erbrauchen?
Nein, es war mehr schleimig,
weil ich habe das letzte Jahr schon gestern Abend gegessen
vor über 12 Stunden.
Und ich hatte heute Morgen ja noch nichts gefrühstückt.
Das war ja vor dem Frühstück.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, kein Fieber.
Nein.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Schütto-Lank
oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, wir sind nur schwindelig.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen von denen ich wissen sollte,
wie Blutwaffe, Diabetes, Konche?
Ich nehme nur ein Medikament ein, das ist für die Schildröse.
Ich habe eine Schildrösenvergrößerung
und wie der Arzt sagt, eine leichte Unterfunktion.
Dafür muss ich dann Tabletten nehmen.
Seit ungefähr 18, 20 Jahren.
Seit 18, 20 Jahren.
Zirka 20 Jahre nehme ich diese Tablette.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Das Mittel heißt Elteroxin.
Eine Morde.
Eine Morde, da steht drauf 50.
50 mg.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Als Kind wurde eine Mandeln operiert.
Da war ich vielleicht acht Jahre alt.
Mit ca. 15 Jahren wurde mein Blinddamm operiert.
Als Sie 15 war?
Ja, 15 Jahre.
Frau Liepert, reagieren Sie auf irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ich habe keine Allergien.
Sind Sie gegen Corona-Bereichung und Kinderkrankheit geimpft?
Ja, ich gehe eigentlich regelmäßig zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Ich bin geimpft dreimal gegen Corona
und habe im April auch eine Covid-Erkrankung gehabt.
Aber alles ist gut verlaufen.
Was ist Ihre Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Letzte Zeit heißt, wie lange?
Letzter Zeit?
Letzter Monat.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche schon ziemlich lange.
Seit ca. 37 Jahren.
Ich habe 30 Jahre.
Haben Sie schon probiert, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören?
Nein.
Wir können vielleicht darüber sprechen.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber sehr selten.
Vielleicht ein Einglaswein in der Woche.
Einglaswein pro Woche.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, Frau Liepert.
Ich muss auch diese Frage stellen.
Nehmen Sie Drohnen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich habe sie schon seit 6 Jahren.
Sie sind 56 Jahre alt.
Sie sind in den Wechseljahren.
Bis vor 6 Jahren habe ich noch die Pille genommen.
Bis vor 6 Jahren.
Danach nicht mehr.
Wie lange haben Sie viele Einnahmen?
Ja, 25 Jahre.
25 Jahre.
Danke.
Frau Liepert, gibt es irgendwelche Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ja, mein Vater ist an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Mit 68 Jahren.
Meine Mutter ist 82 Jahre alt.
Sie hat etwas Alterszucker und etwas hoher Blutdruck.
Ein Bruder von mir.
Moment, bitte.
Ich mache mir Noten.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ja, meine Mutter ist 82 Jahre alt.
Sie hat etwas Alterszucker und etwas hoher Blutdruck.
Ich habe eine Beipass-Operation bekommen.
Sie haben zwei Kinder.
Sie sind 32 Jahre alt und 34 Jahre alt.
Sie leben mit Ihrer Familie?
Nur mit meinem Mann.
Die Kinder haben eigene Familien.
Sie haben eigene Familien.
Sie treiben Sport?
Nein.
Haben Sie Haustiere?
Nur Fische.
Ein Aquarium mit Fischen.
Sehr schön.
Ich habe alle meine Pragen gestellt.
Frau Liepert.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzubügen?
Was kann es sein?
Ich bin ganz verunsichert.
Neugierig.
Deshalb ist mir übel und ich diesen Druck habe.
Frau Liepert.
Als Erster haben wir immer drei Schritte.
Um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Zuerst einer der
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen, wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie Halsrasis, Stolpern?
Vielleicht in den letzten Wochen, wenn Sie mich so fragen, kann das sein, dass ich mal, ich muss, ich muss 2 Stockwerke steigen mit der Treppe.
Und da ist es mal passiert, dass, als ich oben auf einem 2. Stock war, dass mein Herz sehr schnell schlug.
Auch etwas unregelmäßig, aber das wird dann wieder besser.
Haben Sie kalte Schweißigkeit, jetzt momentan?
Vorhin, als ich erbrochen habe, da waren wir auf etwas Schweißig und kalte.
Haben Sie kontrastmittelallergien?
Ich habe noch nie Kontrastmittel bekommen.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Das war es.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Doktor, günstig.
Ja, das war der hier gleich.
Okay.
Können wir anfangen, als Sie uns gechipelt?
Ja.
Okay.
Guten Tag Herr Oberart.
Ich möchte über eine neue Patientin verrichten.
Darf ich?
Ja.
Jutta Liepert ist eine 76-jährige Patientin.
Sie ist groß und ich habe vergessen zu fragen.
Sie ist verreiratet und hat zwei Kinder.
Sie arbeitet aus Architektin.
Sie stellte sich seit zwei Stunden bestellen.
Sie hat sechs Stunden bis zum ersten Tag bestellen.
Sie hat seit zwei Stunden bestellen.
Sie ist geestet.
Mit dem Sinne eines Brockenführes vorhanden.
Ja, retrosthenale Beschwerden.
Und desweiteren klagten die Patienten
über
zweimal aufgetretene
aufgetretene
aufgetretene Erbrochen.
Ja.
Das Erbrochen
sei
gelblich und schleimig gewesen.
Keine Blut
Beide.
Wir fragen nach, Blut wurde vernein.
Okay.
Erbrochene wurde vernein.
Die Patientin, ist die Patientin kreislaufstabil?
Ich hab mich
kontrolliert.
Ja, in diesem Alter
muss man unbedingt
mit einem Beschwerden-Karometer
kontrollieren.
Kontrollieren.
Ja, ich mache gleich.
Okay.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Vorgeschichte?
Gibt es Risikofaktoren bei der Patientin?
Risikofaktoren, ja.
Der Vater, der Vater sei
am einen
Minukartinfarkt
im Alter von
Akkordung 6 gestorben.
Und
die Mutter leide
an Artillerin hip-hypertoni
und Diabetes-Militor.
Und Bruder auch
der Bruder
wurde
wurde wegen
wegen einer
Herzkrankheit, die KK operiert bei fast...
Personalische Risikofaktoren bei der Patient?
Ja, er, Nikotin Abusus wurde mit 37 Packages bejaht.
Das ist ein großer Risikofaktor.
Es besteht bei der Patientin ein Nikotin Abusus über 37 Packages.
Ja, und an vor Erkrankungen er gab sich die Hypotheurelte seit 20 Jahren
und zustand nach von Silektomie im Alter von 8 Jahren.
Was ist Ihr Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, das ist Akut-Corona-Sendron.
Ja, die anernehmend angabendeutend am erhältsten auf eine Akut-Corona-Sendron,
besonders es könnte hinterwärtsinfarkt.
Okay, gut.
Mit der Verdachtsdiagnose bin ich einverstanden.
Was kommt differenzial diagnostisch in Betracht?
Aus differenzial Diagnose kommen...
Die Erhorten-Dissektion, ja.
Die Erhorten-Dissektion kommen in Betra.
Ja, auch Prümoner-Ambulie muss auch ausgeschlossen werden.
Da fehlt vielleicht die ganz akute Disprö im Rahmen der Lunge?
Ja, die Patientin hat keine Düstener.
Sie habe in der letzten Zeit belastungabhängige Herzrasen
und Sie haben Vertigo-Übelkeit.
Die Patientin, die Verdachtsdiagnose auf ein akutes Corona-Sendron,
ist die wichtigste.
Die muss auch, wie der Kollege eben gesagt hat, möglichst früh beachtet werden.
Deswegen, als erstes, wenn Sie die Anamnese erheben
und Frau Lippert hat das Ihnen geschildert mit der Übelkeit und dem Druckgefühl.
Es ist nicht so klassisch wie vielleicht bei manchen Männern,
aber Frauen haben ja manchmal sehr etwas untypische Symptome
des Herzinfarktes.
Da müssen Sie daran denken, als Blutdrucknessen
an den Monitor anlegen, so etwas messen.
Das beruhigt auch die Patientin.
Sie tun etwas, aber machen gleichzeitig die Anamneseerhebung.
Also zu Anfang sagen, Frau Lippert, ich schließe Sie jetzt an einen Monitor an.
Das dient Ihre Überwachung und ich mache ein EKG,
veranleiste ein EKG und messe Ihren Blutdruck.
Dann haben Sie schon mal wichtige Werte.
Eventuell können Sie Ihr dann vielleicht sogar auch ein,
zwei Sprühstöße Nitro-Spray geben,
um zu schauen, ob das vielleicht anspricht
und Ihr diesen Druck verbessert.
Das kann wir parallel machen lassen oder machen.
Wichtig ist in so einem Fall,
eine sehr gezielte Anamnese zu machen,
um auch handeln zu können.
Die anderen Dinge,
die Sie vielleicht in einer Wohnung oder Haus haben,
die sind zwar auch wichtig,
aber vorderwohnen steht jetzt erst mal die Akutdiagnostik
und Akutbehandlung, um nichts zu übersehen.
Das ist, finde ich, sehr wichtig.
Ich denke, Sie haben medizinische Fachbegriffe einige genannt.
Denken Sie noch dran an Übelkeit
und Erbrechung,
das würde ich da nicht sagen,
sondern nause ja, vomitus,
dass es noch leicht gemacht werden.
Und nicht sagen Oberkörper Druck,
sondern Schmerz,
dann sollten Sie sagen,
überwiegend retro Sternale Beschwerden,
um das Ganze eben in dieses Fachmedizinische zu übersetzen.
Wenn Sie etwas überlegen,
ich mache es jetzt mal vor,
machen Sie ganz oft so.
Und dann halten Sie Ihren Pop
und dann halten Sie die Hand teilweise vor den Mund dabei.
Versuchen Sie das nicht zu machen.
Lieber halten Sie sich an einem Bleistift fest,
an einem Schreiber und am Blattpapier,
dass Sie nicht die Hand so ins Gesicht unter vornähen.
Das ist dann oft schwer verständlich vielleicht,
aber es ist souveräner,
wenn Sie möglichst offen sitzen und nicht die Hand so davor haben.
Ist mit nur jetzt aufgefallen.
Sie darf vielleicht darauf achten.
Und lieber,
im Anfang, auch wenn es vielleicht dann gar nicht stimmt,
aber lieber im Anfang sagen,
ich schließe Sie an einem Monitor an,
ich messe Ihnen den Blutdruck
und gegebenenfalls vielleicht ein EKG,
dann haben Sie das Mötigste erst mal gemacht
und damit brauchen Sie sich auch keine Vorwürfe machen lassen.
Das ist erst mal wichtig.
Deswegen hat der Moderator ja auch durchaus gesagt,
ich komme von der Kardiologie
und ich kümmere mich jetzt so drum.
Das war schon sehr hilfreich.
Ja, manchmal
Das ist schwierig, weiß ich.
Aber dafür machen wir jetzt ja diese Training.
Gut.
Und Sie haben
ein Video,